[Music]
meagan Markel and Prince Harry's royal
wedding invitations have been sent out
and it looks like not everyone made the
cut we've been here from the very
beginning I mean our whole life just
always rooting her on and supporting her
that's Megan's nephew Tyler Dooley and
his mother Tracey Dooley who is divorced
from the bride-to-be his half-brother
Thomas Markel jr. the two sat down with
a British Morning Show good morning
Britain on Monday and revealed they
still hadn't received invites to the May
19th nuptials problem I don't think that
we're going to get the invitations and
that's just that's fine we're okay with
that
but we're supporting her on and just
having a good time so proud of her and
to be fair the mother son duo admitted
they haven't spoken to Megan in years he
T reported back in December that the 36
year old was planning to include both
her father Thomas Markel and her mother
Dorie a rattlin on her special day at
the time a source told ET quote Megan
asked her father to walk her down the
aisle and last week royal expert Katie
Nichols said the former suit star won't
have a lot of family in attendance in
terms of who megan is inviting from her
family it may well just be her mother
and her father my sources told me this
is very much estranged from her half
brother and her half sister and there's
extended members of the family and I
think if you've spoken publicly you're
not gonna make that wedding list
you
[Music]